you have to surround yourself with
people that are going to move you higher
as Oprah said or somebody's Irish I was
like 10 I was with my dad at his office
I was like I'm one of the interns
computers or something and I'm thinking
to my 10 year old self hey I'm gonna
look up boys calm I'm sure it's gonna be
full of fire trucks
it wasn't that's when I first started
feeling the subtraction to it my mom
caught me but year or two after that and
she flipped out I kind of saw how my mom
reacted to how like other black people
would react especially how I thought my
dad would react I thought I had my [ __ ]
all hidden folder after folder after
folder and my brother happened to find
some clips and then he called it out in
front of my mom
and I was mortified and I mean I guess
the writing is on the damn wall at that
point I was just like well like Here I
am I'm gay I do you have a problem with
it if you do I don't care when someone
tells you you're something and you can't
pull it out you don't listen and York
nope nope and then there was no one else
15 I was like wait am i gay and my heart
sunk because I knew what that meant
and it was hard you know just took that
feeling of being scared to just be
yourself no one should have to go
through that my parents were super super
super strict Catholics I went through
the whole like we called it religion
class very traditional and it was always
talking about man and woman and I'm just
like what huh I was also a minority in
terms of my religion that I grew up in
we were the only black family in the
church you know but the Mormon religion
is so misunderstood because I can tell
you without a shadow of a doubt that
I've never once felt bullied or like I
wasn't seeing the church that I grew up
in was totally apolitical yeah I didn't
really feel that kind of homophobia that
does happen in the black church I'm till
my family switch churches while I was
away I'm there in the service know like
we're going to sign this petition after
service and let them know that we don't
this gay marriage whatever whatever and
I'm like okay no stop and my dad's like
warm why are you so upset and I'm like
because I think I'm gay dad and he just
looks at me and he's like well I mean
you didn't have a girlfriend all high
school I'm not stupid masculinity in my
home was expressed through sports and I
started flipping off [ __ ] and I ended up
getting getting into gymnastics because
I wanted to be like Dominique Dawes and
my parents you know supported it I still
support my crazy dreams I was a damn
good athlete people think because I'm
feminine that I can't beat you in a
track race but I grew up very lucky to
have a family that focused on my talent
and my skills and not what they didn't
understand so far as like black gay
characters or black female characters
like I didn't really seeing much of
myself especially like back then like
they were always so stereotypical I will
say that when I saw Brent Collins Jesse
L Martin's character it was like out
proud HIV positive gay man's the first
kind of breaking up that stereotyping I
kind of saw a little bit of myself there
and the fact that he was dating this
awesome drag queen like was very cool
and that was kind of the first time I
saw myself so completely in a character
Carrie Washington when she was falling
into those roles where they wanted her
to be that ghetto girl and she killed it
and that inspired me to embrace my
blackness now she's doing scandal and
that inspired me to know that I am
powerful beyond belief you can go from
the streets of Brooklyn to the White
House growing up I used to run home
every day and watch Oprah to this day
this woman has probably inspired so many
black people white people queer people
straight people everybody
she really had that like voice of reason
that I looked up to every day the
hardest part at least for me was
figuring out how it could be like
confident in my blackness and confident
in my homosexuality so often there's so
much negativity from one of those to the
other I have learned too
really invest in really good friendships
the journey I think is finding people
outside of your family I was like dad
this person said and this and I can tell
my family that I'm gay he said the only
thing that gets me mad is that you
waited so long to tell me I mean I'm
still emotional about - because we don't
speak on it I wish that I could see
ahead of time and see that it isn't
gonna be that bad the world is infinite
the possibilities are endless and there
are a billion different paths for you
bigger than you liking men or bigger
than you having dark skin those two
things or things to be so proud of the
black community has a Don't Ask Don't
Tell
type policy it's okay to speak on it and
when you do you can have a beautiful
relationship of love and support love in
the black community needs to be
highlighted and expressed you're gonna
go to school you're gonna learn and then
you're gonna get a bomb-ass job and
you're gonna build your career and
you're gonna be [ __ ] great you can do
it now go do it
make make us all proud
Wow